gamers i hold before you the cutie pie
shaker it's now available so i make a
cool effect
this is my favorite one so far nice job
teams
that's something vinta
these bad boys get sold out quick so if
you want one don't wait link consider
script yeah
and another reason if you're not sold
yet despite the fact that this is the
best cup in the world they sold that
quickly thirty percent off if you use
code pewdiepie thirty percent if there's
ever a time to be like if you uh now now
it's the time gamers now you wanna be
better at games or what can't you tell
how good i am at games it's only valid
as long as the supply lasts don't be one
of these people that wait for the supply
to unlast itself shaker is 9.99 but also
we got a new pewdiepie tub
that's right
it's floor gang flavor now it's the same
flavor as before but even better how do
we improve the recipe we changed nothing
because you can't improve perfection
gamers we just changed the package i
drink this every day i love g-fuel it's
legitimately the best it tastes good you
hydrate you epic gamer what else could
you want what you're still drinking
canned drinks
that's awesome because we sell those too
i don't know what type it's a delicious
g-fuel flavor and it's 30 up check it
out gamers link ba-bamba
book review
book review why is he wearing headphones
shut up anyway
um
i'm sorry i'm horribly late i am so late
i've been busy okay i also planned this
very very poorly okay
we read epic titties discourses and
selected writings
did you love it did you hate it what
would you rate it not many people
complained that i was so late so i
assume no one read it
the five people that actually did
be like bro can you say epic theaters
without giggling like a squirrel girl
it's got epic and tits in it that's
hilarious
i picked this book because it's fairly
simple it's straightforward and it's a
good introduction to stoic philosophy um
there's probably better examples but
this is what i chose i
really really like this book
it's one of the few books that make me
feel
fortunate as uh
sounds a bit cringe almost to say but
fortunate as a human to be able to
experience i i really mean that i don't
care if it's cringe actually not just
for its content but also the fact that
it did survive which is not to be taken
for granted earlier works of stoics like
crucifix
didn't survive and this has been around
for two thousand years so that's great
it was written by aaron
who was epictetus student and he wrote
down his teacher's
words word for word
and i assumed he just thought hey this
is epic i'm gonna write this down other
people might have some use of this
fun fact aaron also wrote alexander the
great's autobiography
it's kind of funny how everything in the
greek canon seems to be so connected
i said this before but and you probably
know
plato learned from socrates
aristotle studied in plato's school
alexander the great was taught by
aristotle it's just
and in this book as well there's many
great anecdotes from diogenes which i
made a video about as well which was
unexpected and really really fun so the
more you dwell into it the more you get
out of it and i really love that and the
reason i brought this up as well is
because stoicism
takes its roots or its beginnings around
the time of aristotle's death and it
heavily derives from socrates and plato
and aristotle but i would say the main
difference there are obviously a couple
is that
stoicism is philosophy more as a way of
life i've explained this before but the
general explanation i hear about what
stoicism is but it's become fairly
popular recently is that there are
things in life that you can control and
there are things in life that you can't
control and whatever you can't control
you shouldn't let bother you they
shouldn't make you feel angry or sad and
i think that's a good example because
it's something that most people can
relate to already or you've taken this
into practice maybe without naturally
without even thinking about it it's
easier to
cope or deal with things if we recognize
well this is out of my control i can't
do anything about about it if you miss
the bus one day maybe you think instead
of getting upset about it you can try
and appreciate getting a good walk
positive thinking everyone
that's not really civicism but i mean in
a sense
stoicism is that for
everything which sometimes might seem a
bit extreme but it's also
in every sense necessary to be free as
an individual to be truly free which
we'll get into later i think these
smaller examples are good and
if we would let any single thing that
doesn't go our way bother us then we
would just live life in constant
distress and according to epictetus
being angry or feeling sorrow are just
not useful emotions because he says when
did anger however ever teach someone to
play music or pilot a [ __ ] do you
imagine that anger is going to help
teach me the far more complex business
of life well it won't um so in the sense
that there are things in life that we
can and we can't control the book
actually starts off in book one
discourses with concerning what is in
our power and what is not and epictetus
begins to explain that we naturally
unbound ourselves to things bound to
these headphones for seemingly no reason
but wanting to cover up my hair uh i'm
[ __ ]
i'm bound to this camera because uh i
needed to film this video i'm bound to
the computer i'm bound to this desk in
this chair this is where the whole floor
gang meme come from i don't need it
technically but also we bound ourselves
to maybe even other people friends and
family and
our children we see them as sort of an
extension of ourselves but according to
epictetus because we bound ourselves to
many things they depress us and they
weigh us down and he starts off by
giving a smaller example if we want to
sail and we look out to the sea and the
wind isn't blowing in our favor we look
out to sea and torment ourselves hoping
that the wind will change again
but what really is it to us it is not in
our power to control nature and and
these things that we bound ourselves to
we sort of feel a sense of ownership of
but we don't own any of it you may think
you own your house but at any point um i
mean unlikely but it could get destroyed
your friends and family
could pass away at any moment and so can
you
or they could leave and so can you and
it goes as far as even your own body
doesn't belong to you because as you may
control
control it in a sense you also can't
control it being in perfect health you
can't make it perform exactly as you
wish so
from that logic it doesn't belong to you
and this is easier to see with smaller
things
like okay i don't own this book
uh sure
but it's important to grasp for
everything not just to avoid sorrow and
pain but to also to develop your own
personal freedom which is my favorite
part of the book
and a surprising piece that really
yeah we'll get into that later
so just because
we can't control these things or the
outcome of them that doesn't mean you
can can't enjoy them or that you can't
participate or even influence the world
uh it's rather recognizing that that's a
difficult thing to do uh changing
people's minds for example but i would
argue that as soic even appreciate in a
sense things further because they see
them for what they really are according
to its nature and according to nature is
a phrase that you hear a lot of in
stoicism a stoic's goal is after all to
live life according to nature and to put
it simply this means that
you see the world for what it is and
therefore you accept it you accept
age you accept loss you accept death
everything from simple to the weather so
on this principle of living according to
nature
you might ask then well why should i
just
live like
whatever i please why should i not just
fill myself with food or drink or give
into any sensational pleasure that i
want well be that's because we may not
control all these other things but the
only thing that we control is our will
and that is what controls our actions so
let's say for example
crazy example they enjoy maybe drinking
whiskey in the evening
that might satisfy a desire that you
have but
ultimately you are all you are bound to
that desire then and according to
epictetus we should try and eliminate
our desires because otherwise we are
bound to them and otherwise our actions
is really the only thing that we can
control in book one there's a really
good quote it says i must die was i then
die lamenting i must be put in chains
unless i then also lament i must go into
exile does any man then hinder me from
going with smiles and cheerfulness and
contentment tell me the secret which you
possess i will not for this is in my
power but i will put you in chains man
what are you talking about me in chains
you may father my leg but my will not
even sues himself can overpower so again
whatever is in our own action is what we
ultimately have power over or ownership
of and and no one not even the gods in a
sense can take that away from us this is
according to epictetus the most supreme
gift that we are given as humans and
it's the only thing that we have that
examines itself what it is and and what
power it has and through our will and
developing of reason which we gain when
we get older we see things differently
and we act differently because of it
some people can live life without being
disturbed by certain events other people
struggle more or less
and
what action we take through in an event
is through our opinion of that thing he
gives the example here of achilles this
then was the cause of achilles
lamentations not the fact that patroclus
died since other people don't carry on
so when a friend or companion dies but
the fact that he chose to the man so
this example is from homer's elliot
where achilles
uh lost his best friend petroculus you
may have heard of you probably know i
kill this already and he's he's famous
for being this ultimate warrior and the
only weakness he had was his heel
but i guess you could say that according
to epictetus his weakness wasn't uh he
was healed but his opinion that that was
his fault because his view on on death
was not according to nature and he gives
another great quote that sort of ties
into that because this might i recognize
this might seem very harsh or
crude to impose on someone's view on
death
but
he says you wish for these things in
winter you are a fool so if you wish for
your son or your friend when it's not
allowed to you you must know that you
are wishing for a fig in winter for such
as winter is to a fig such as every
event which happens from the universe to
the things which are taken away
according to its nature and further at
the times when you are delighted with a
thing place before yourself the contrary
appearances what harm is it while you
are kissing your child to say with a
lisping voice tomorrow you will die and
to a friend also tomorrow you will go or
i shall and never shall we see one
another again again according to
ebitda's anger and and sorrow are just
emotions that will not help us through
life and it's not to suppress these
emotions and sort of hold them in but
it's rather by seeing things for what
they are you accept them instead of
trying to fight it or bargain with it
arguing against nature is something that
you do as a child because you haven't
yet developed that reason and
and only a child would ask for a
fig in winter a stoic is always aware of
death they sort of live i guess you
could say
near death so by saying thing according
to its nature that opinion of death
might seem
heavy or or overbearing almost uh to be
constantly aware of it but it's also
very liberating epictetus gives the
example of diogenes as a man who was
truly free because everything he owned
he could dispose of and was only
temporarily attached to him
he says if you grabbed him by the leg he
would have given up the leg if you had
seized his entire body the entire body
would have been sacrificed the same with
family friends and country he knew where
they had come from from whom and on what
terms so diogenes news that these things
didn't belong to him so he was also then
free from them while still
being able to enjoy them
if you imagine a free person you might
imagine someone with a lot of wealth a
lot of power
they can do what they want they can go
wherever they want uh they can control
people
but you could still argue that they are
humbled to their wealth uh money can
give freedom but they can also bound you
to it and then ultimately in that same
sense being a slave to it because if
something were to happen with it and if
you or if you're awake at night worried
that something might happen to all the
money you have you then also don't have
an opinion according to its nature and
you are also
not free from it epictetus himself was a
slave during his life so he must have
thought about this a lot uh on the theme
of freedom and i think he knew that his
opinion was not a popular one he says
that he if you tell someone that they
are just as enslaved as someone sold to
captivity don't expect anything but a
punch in the nose
and i think it's a reality that we don't
like to admit uh we prefer to see
ourselves as free individuals even if
it might seem like we are or but in
general we are all bound to certain
things so from a stoic sense you are not
we sometimes even let our actions be
bound to
not things but the opinion that other
people have of it maybe you picked your
job or your school or your partner
through opinion aren't you asleep to
other people's opinion then so according
to epic titties you can be a slave but
still be a free man as long as your
actions are free and as long as you're
not bound to anything that's what really
makes the difference and i think that's
a
a hopeful and liberating view on the
world i would say um life is just full
of things that you can't control but to
try and focus on your own views and your
own opinions to liberate yourself
there's to me a lot of power in that
there are so many great pieces of this
book and i feel like i could just read
quote after quote after chord until i
just read the whole book i highly
recommend it it's just filled with so
many great parts i wanted to finish by
reading just some my favorite bit which
is just a small sentence in the very
very end because it resonates heavily
with me let someone point out to me a
man who can say i care only about the
things which are my own the things which
are not subject of hindrance the things
which are by nature free this i hold to
be the nature of the good but let all
other things be as they are allowed i do
not concern myself that's it epictetus
discourse in selected writing
check it out what did you think of it
did you read it i would love to hear you
guys thoughts and did you get the same
ideas from me that i had or something
completely different uh next week
uh it will not be next week but next
book
we're gonna read arthur schopenhauer uh
the wisdom of life i recently discovered
schopenhauer he's great really fun to
read and i think you guys will enjoy him
as well if you enjoy philosophy or
reading in general er it's a fun one i
like it he's a goofy guy and that's it
hope you guys enjoyed see you next time
bye bye